Denver is on the line Heather's calling
hi Heather how are you fine thanks Dave
for taking the call sure what's up
well my situation is I am 48 years old
when I was 45 and my wonderful husband
was also 45 he passed away from cancer
and we're together married for 23 years
and had a really great strong marriage
and one thing we always did is we were
always looking below our means we saved
well we paid cash for a lot of things
and because of that and because we're
smart enough to make sure we had health
and life insurance we were able to stay
home continue to stay home with my
children and kind of take the time to
get back into the workforce I have been
lucky enough you know three years later
to find a second love and it's wonderful
and we're fairly serious but I am kind
of concerned and this is where my
question comes in because I do have
quite a few assets and he comes to this
situation with actually a very good
income and I really don't have one you
know I'm kind of curious about what you
think about a prenuptial agreement
how much in Essos do you have I have
about 3.8 million yes you need a prenup
so you don't see it as you know I just
feel like well what the only time I I
dislike prenups and I generally tell
people not to do prenups and for years I
told them to never do them because I
always said if you love your money more
and you love somebody else then don't
marry them they're not really okay but
here's the problem I've run into because
I started working with a lot of very
wealthy people and you're a very wealthy
person and you're your feet potential
fiance or fiance is not
mm-hmm and the problem is not you too
the problem is that numbers of this size
invite crazy into your life in one way
or another and I don't know which door
it's going to use so I don't know
which door to tell you to lock so what
do you mean I mean well I'm just saying
I don't know if it's his mother I don't
know if it's his kid I don't know if
it's his first cousin I don't know if
it's one of your kids but somebody goes
off the ranch and starts affecting this
whole situation all of a sudden and and
then the legacy that was your first
marriage is destroyed because you didn't
have this in place and I don't really
suspect either one of you you the two
people involved you're not usually the
problem but it's somebody that one ring
out that goes into crazy mode are always
already in crazy mode it just hasn't
been exposed yet and I see it with
athletes I see it with artists and
that's where I started running into it
now you guys are pretty functional
people obviously there's not a lot of
toxicity around you or in this situation
you're stable you know people with high
values and those kinds of things which
causes you to be disturbed by even
asking the question those are wonderful
indicators that crazy is probably not
that close to you but you can be and
there's just too much on the line here
and so what I would want to do is just
take that off the table now what you
could do is choose and I would not make
it a part of the prenup but I would
choose to say we might rewrite this
thing every so many years and move
portions of it out to where let's say
you're married 30 more years okay then
maybe at that point it's all ours
sure because we built a life together
but for the first five years no okay how
do you how do you broach that we've
talked a lot about finances we're both
very clear in what we both you know are
debt free and we have a lot of the same
values so how do you approach that so I
mean like the way you said it's not you
I'm concerned about it's all the people
around that could cause our relationship
and there's just there's too much
imbalance we're not bringing equal
amounts to the table and the only reason
I do it is because you're in an extreme
situation I don't I don't suggest a
prenup except in extreme situations and
this is an extreme situation and just I
would say I want to do it to protect our
relationship so that
never any hint that this money is a
problem it's just not in it's not in the
discussion it's not a problem and so
we've got enough other things to deal
with hey thanks for the call
you